with a group of ukrainians
uh i've been
learning ukrainian and they were having
a great discussion i understood
everything they had to say i couldn't
really express myself very well
but i know that if i were set if i were
in a situation where i had to speak
ukrainian i could learn it very quickly
and i've had that experience so many
times that i'm with people from china
japan france brazil and i'm able to
communicate with them so language
learning is a wonderful thing to do yet
a majority of people
somehow believe they can't learn or
they've had
an unhappy experience or they're
frustrated and so forth
now you i would imagine most of you are
very successful language learners but
nevertheless
if you have questions about language
learning
i want to hear them and i want to share
with you my experience
those of you who have
followed my youtube channel you know
that i'm a great believer in stephen
krashen's
approach which is that language learning
is largely a matter of input of
meaningful
input in other words the language has to
come from outside and has to come into
our brains from outside we have to get
used to the language the conference is
now unlocked our wonderful ways of doing
this
another thing that i refer to quite
often in my youtube videos
is what i call the three keys
number one is to have a positive
attitude towards language learning to
like the language to enjoy the process
number two is to spend enough time
because it does take time and number
three is to develop the ability to
notice what's happening in the language
and i've talked about this quite a bit
in my videos and what we've done at linc
is try to develop a tool that helps
people notice
so i want to have a very short
introduction because i talk all the time
on my youtube channel
today is an opportunity
to get questions from you
okay ah is that better
but the sound wasn't very good i guess
so first question here uh from victor
steve often says that you should do
things that are interesting like reading
and listening to things you like to
learn better but how do i learn a
language just from reading something
that i can't understand okay very good
question
obviously when you start in the language
you can only deal with very limited
content
uh limited meaning it should be short
it should have relatively basic
vocabulary in it
i will often if i'm starting from
scratch i'll buy a little starter book
like teach yourself or colloquial
and and these exist in many languages
and so you get a little bit of an
overview of how the language works
i find it very difficult to remember
the specific grammar
rules or patterns or structures
but getting a brief overview helps you
and and mostly then i'm driven by
this effort to try to understand the
content
and so i save words or before link i
would look up the little glossary the
word list for a particular lesson and
then i would try to understand as much
as i could
of the the specific text which might
only be 20 seconds long and maybe i
listened to it once or two twice or
three times and i still don't understand
it and i read it again and i review the
words so
there's that initial period where you
have to try to get some traction in the
language because initially it's all
noise or it's all words that have no
meaning it's just letters or script on
the page and you have to convert that
into something that has meaning so yeah
a good question in the beginning it's
not so much fun
however
the advantage in the beginning is that
there's this tremendous sense of
excitement
as something that was just noise or
scribblings uh you know just writing
all of a sudden starts to have some
meaning
and so i feel that that when i first
start with a language this excitement
that discovering a new language
kind of sustains me it's new it's
interesting is it it's exciting but
within a month or two
i find that i have to move on to
something that has meaning i can't keep
reading
about you know jim and and and juan
who
you know met at school and all of the
sort of um
learner content that's created for
learners and i think it's very
unfortunate when people
even when they're intermediate they
continue to only use this sort of
learner content which is extremely
uninteresting so
i think
my strategy is initially to get some
traction i have to deal with
uninteresting content
i have even in the case of romanian
drafted up some 200 uh sentences
in in english that dealt with some of
the basic concepts that i want to be
able to express say in romanian i had
someone translate these and record them
so this became my my in learning content
to get me started in the language but
within a month or so with romanian
because the vocabulary is so similar to
italian pretty soon i'm into uh
meaningful content about history and
these are things that i find enjoyable
and if the content is enjoyable i don't
mind the fact that i don't understand it
all i don't mind the fact that i have to
look up a lot of words because i'm
attracted by the interest in the content
so that would be my answer to your
question victor
uh i hope
uh yeah by the way
uh i should point out that this question
and answer
button ask a question button is at the
top of the screen for those of you who
want to post some questions
uh
if i hope that answers your question
victor
all right
one of the problems with the webinar is
of course i can't have the feedback from
from victor
uh next question here from thiago
how do i know i'm improving even it's
when it seems i'm stuck for months in a
language
that's a an excellent question
um
first of all
i mean i've been in that situation
myself
you have to
believe
that with
more and more exposure to the language
uh
you will get better you're not going to
get worse you can only get better even
though there are periods of time when
you feel that you're not making progress
and and what happens is typically there
may even be periods of time where you
feel you're doing worse than you were
doing before
but all of a sudden there'll be a moment
when
a text that
perhaps you had difficulty with before
all of a sudden is clear to you or
you're in with a group of people and all
of a sudden you express yourself better
than you had done before and these
moments come but it's not constant and
so you have to basically believe that
you are get you have to have that sense
that you are getting better
and
also this relates to this idea of
of reading and listening to
things that are of interest to you so
if i'm uh
you know learning say
portuguese and and but i'm listening to
an interesting podcast or i'm reading
something interesting
i'm more sort of motivated by the fact
that i'm i'm learning things about maybe
brazil or portugal or or whatever it
might be that i'm i'm actually enjoying
engaging with the content
so i'm not too concerned about how
quickly am i improving
that doesn't concern me that much
now there is a difference between of
course understanding and speaking and i
emphasize
comprehension because i think if you
understand what people are saying if you
have good comprehension and good
vocabulary
you can do so much you can watch movies
you can read books you can listen to
podcasts
but when it comes to speaking of course
you have to speak and you have to speak
a lot
but if you have good comprehension then
you can participate in discussions you
can understand what people are saying
and with good comprehension you will
gradually improve so
personally i don't worry so much about
whether have a sense that i'm improving
uh
and at link of course we have instituted
all of our statistics and they're there
to provide you sort of confirmation
reassurance that you have learned so
many more words and and that in fact you
are improving but thiago the answer to
your question is yeah very often we have
the sense that we're not improving uh we
have to try to enjoy the process believe
that we are improving and every now and
again we get this confirmation that wow
look at what i've achieved so i hope
that answers your question
okay
um
now next question from ken matsunaga
what is the fastest way to study who is
she in japanese who is she
is a uh
a lesson or a syria course uh at link
uh many of you have uh have uh studied
who is she which exists in i don't know
12 13 languages and who is she
at link so that
you have a translation of the meaning
now
the fastest way to study
any lesson
in my opinion is first of all i am not
obsessed with fast
uh you know the second of the three keys
is language learning takes time
so the question perhaps should be what
is the most effective way to study any
particular lesson well typically who is
she
is a course
that you study at the beginning
and it takes it starts uh at a very
basic level and then it ramps up to a
more difficult level so what i did when
i used who is she for russian and for
czech and for korean
is that i would study lesson one
two three four five
didn't understand uh you know i go
through because they're quite short i'd
go through lesson one review the words
listen once or twice kind of don't
understand it go on to lesson two and
because it's a story then it continues
from lesson one to lesson two so you're
actually following the development of
this story and so i would take on
lessons one to five for the first week
and i listened to them many many times
and then i would move on to six seven
eight nine ten the same way and then i
would again listen from one through ten
uh and so forth then i do 11 to 15 and
i'll find some of them no matter how
often i listen i still can't understand
and then maybe i understand 18 better
than 14 it doesn't matter it's just this
idea that you're constantly exposing
yourself to the language you're saving
new words and phrases in link you're
reviewing those words you're reading and
listening and you understand you go away
and you listen on your mp3 player you
don't understand and you just continue
investing this time in the in in the
process and and at the end of it you're
going through from 1 to 25 quite often
and and
who is she to me is a basically a
fundamental
course which takes takes you from a very
low level to almost an intermediate
level and i spent with russia i spent
two months on who is she
in order to get a base and once i had
that base then i could actually go into
russian literature although there were a
lot of unknown words i felt that i had
enough of a sense of the language that i
could then start to take on
content that was of interest to me so i
hope that answers your question ken
now let's move on here
uh
yes here echoing problem the echo is
really bad presumably okay what advice
can you give us about translating in
your head while listening to a new
language all right
i think it is inevitable initially that
we do some of that translating um
personally one of the reasons why i i'm
not fond of sort of dual language books
and things of that nature is i try to
stay in the language itself
and initially
of course i'm i'm picking up individual
words with my with an online dictionary
or if you're at link you're you're
saving these words into your database
and and
you know you're struggling because even
having looked up these words
the meaning is not clear
uh because we're not used to the the new
structures of the language
you know because they typically in
different languages they have different
word order they have different ways of
saying things
i
i don't know i just try to stay in the
language i try not to translate it's
inevitable
particularly when we speak we and before
we're very comfortable in the language
we'll think it through in our own
language and then try to say it in the
new language but as we pick up more and
more natural phrases
uh as we pick up more and more natural
phrases
then we start to use these phrases
uh without thinking
so you know for example in in russian if
you say menya zavutz steve you know
it means like they call me steve but you
don't think of it in those terms you
just oh what's your name and i said with
steve you start using
phrases naturally
and so it's just a natural process i
don't think there's any specific um
instruction
or advice that i can give about
translating in your head it's it's
something that's going to stay with you
both when you when you read or listen
and and when you speak until you get
comfortable enough in the language until
you know if you want to express an idea
you naturally go to this phrase that
you've learned that starts to naturally
come out of your mouth
just because you've heard it so often
and and that's where noticing is so
important that's why
in link you should save phrases and
review these phrases so these phrases
become the natural way to express a
certain um thought
okay
i hope that answers that question
thanks very much for hosting my question
what would you say the biggest mistakes
are these would be language learning for
a beginners b intermediate c adventurers
and would you say they were different
for each level
okay um
you know i think
mistake
it's hard to say first of all i think
different people have different things
that they like to do
now a beginner if they are also not
experienced language learners
i think the biggest mistake is first of
all a lot of beginners
um don't think they're going to become
fluent in the language
so they have a psychological or sort of
an attitude problem
obviously an experienced language
learner is confident that they will be
able to learn the language so i think
that's a big issue for beginners
another one is that the beginners i
think try too hard
to nail down say
you know if they've learned 10 new words
they want to try and really learn those
10 new words or if they're introduced to
a new
um
grammatical pattern or even a grammar
rule then they want to make sure they
get that correct or they're going to
answer questions and then they're upset
if they
continually make the same mistake or
forget the same thing
as an experienced language learner i
never do that i don't expect to remember
words i don't expect to remember
grammatical structures uh i i will
review some grammar rules
because i think it kind of helps me look
for things
but
until i've had a lot of exposure to the
language
the grammar rules
i just won't a sometimes even understand
them and certainly won't remember them
um so i'm quite comfortable with that
i'm comfortable with with studying
lessons and not understanding it all
i think beginners very often
are too concerned about trying to nail
down what they're learning certain
uh certain words and grammar structures
you'll learn right away others
not for six months
you know uh
i often for example i mean a good
example of this is i'm sure most people
who study english
are taught very early that uh the third
person singular has an s you know i go
you go he goes
we go they go you know whatever only the
third person singular has an s very
simple rule and yet
for many people this never kicks in and
so they will continue to say he go
uh so so
there's no telling when these rules will
kick in so that it's i think a beginner
too often
uh is too determined to nail things down
and i think that's a disadvantage for
intermediates i would say the biggest
uh mistake intermediates make is they
stay too long in learner
content an intermediate once you're an
intermediate you should be into real
meaningful content you shouldn't be
doing uh stories about uh you know at
the post office and at the train station
and other content that's created for
learners
and advanced learners i think advanced
learners some advanced learners are good
at reading and listening and are
reluctant to speak
once you're advanced or even as an
intermediate you have to go out and talk
you have to go out and talk because you
only get better at speaking by speaking
so that would be my answer for harry's
question now alexander
when you say the more languages you
learn the easier it gets what do you
mean by that is it easier to learn words
does the language make sense quicker i
hope you can elaborate
i think the more languages you learn
there are a number of advantages
first advantage is
that you're more confident that you can
do it so your whole attitude is i've
done this before i mean if you've
climbed a mountain and you're going to
climb a second mountain you're pretty
confident you can do it if you've never
climbed a mountain you probably are a
little
apprehensive
so that's the first thing you are
confident that you can do it the second
of all you probably developed some
learning habits
in learning the first language so then
you take all of this experience into
learning the second language and of
course the third thing the third thing
is
that if you are learning if you've
learned let's say spanish then obviously
it's going to be easier to learn italian
or portuguese if you've learned russian
it'll be easier to learn maybe polish so
once you've learned a language or two or
even if you've learned chinese you can
take all of that chinese vocabulary and
it'll help you learn japanese because a
lot of languages are related to other
languages
and and i think the final thing is that
if we only have one language then our
brain is kind of
somewhat rigid we only you know our
range the range of sounds that we're
familiar with is more limited the kind
of structures
that uh
that we're familiar with is more limited
but once you've learned two or three
things become more flexible in terms of
sounds in terms of structures and so you
have less resistance because one of the
big problems with language learners is
that they resist you know why does this
why do they say it that way in that
language that's stupid you know they
should say it the way
we say it in my native language though
so that this kind of resistance to the
novelty of the new language
disappears you're you're quite
comfortable with the fact that
different languages will express things
in different ways uh
the same uh you know
vowels in fact are pronounced somewhat
differently in different languages none
of this is a surprise we don't resist it
so for all of those reasons uh the more
languages you learn the better a
language early learner you become which
language is language are you learning
now i would say i'm focusing a bit on
korean but i'm still working on my
ukrainian dabbling a bit in polish but i
simply don't have time
next question from martin what do you
think about starting language learning
with us emil
asimil is fine
it's to me it's it's no different from
teach yourself it has some advantages
and some disadvantages if i consider
asimil a starter series so you have
assimil teach yourself colloquial and in
french or in portuguese or in russian
they would have other series that get
you started in a language
asimil the big advantage with assameal
is that all of the content
is in the target language alone which is
a disadvantage with teach yourself
because there's too much
uh you know i hate it when they
introduce the lesson in english
uh i only want the target language
what i don't like about sml is
they don't give you a glossary but they
give you a translation and i find it
very distracting to go to a translation
uh i find a lot of their notes not that
helpful
so but it's i have a similar assimil for
russian the content was quite
interesting acid milk for korean the
content was not interesting so it may
also depend on the language
but to me it's just a starter a place to
get started it's fine
and some people really like gasimil so
next one from olga how often to study
when you start learning the language
well
you know it depends how much time you
have but uh
in my own case
uh i would say 75 percent of my learning
time if not 80
is just listening so uh if i'm in the
car i listen if i am doing the dishes or
cleaning up around the house i listen um
when i'm exercising i listen so i
managed to get in
about
you know three quarters of an hour or an
hour of just listening most days
and i mean how often to study you have
to study you should be going every day
you might miss the odd day but try to
study i would say an hour a day
at a minimum and then of course because
i study with link so then i listen then
i go and i read and i say words and i
review the words and then i go and
listen again
so um yeah you should you know whenever
and it's not just when you're starting
at any stage in the language you have to
i'd like to put in an hour a day i think
that's a quite a minimum
is it a good thing to progress if i read
a book with different language
i'm not sure i understand the question
reading is a very good thing to do
so reading is a great thing to do for
language learning and when you reach the
point where you can actually read a
novel that's a major achievement it's
like climbing a mountain
and i can't stress enough how powerful
reading and reading things of interest
how how powerful an activity that is for
language learning
how do you know from peter how do you
learn more than one language of mixing
them up i tried arabic and russian at
the same time and had to give up arabic
as my russian i have to give up arabic
as my russian was getting worse and i
was mixing them up terribly
well
uh
i think if
i tend to concentrate on one language at
a time
particularly if i'm if it's a new
language to me
but i can
sort of focus 75 80 percent of my time
on one language
and then occasionally
do stuff in another language so that i'm
improving in it as well so at the most i
think
two languages
uh
having said that right now i i listen to
russian but my russian is at a stage
where i understand it essentially all of
it if i listen to it
so that almost doesn't count as learning
and ukrainian is almost at that stage
although i don't speak it very well i
understand it so i'm focusing on korean
and i think it is difficult to take on
two languages at the same time but some
people do it so so i'm only speaking
from my own experience
what is the adequate amount of time to
listen to a certain text
uh you know if we look at link for
example
uh
you know i
i don't think there's a rule it depends
how interested i am in in the content
earlier on uh i tend to spend more time
with with a specific text
um
later on i would may only listen once as
i said when i uh described my uh
approach to learning with who is she uh
i mean i'll spend two months on those 26
lessons and each one of those so that's
26 minutes of content roughly and it was
my basic uh learning material for for
two months when i started into russian
so earlier on you have to listen over
and over again to the same material
but i will move on even if i don't
understand it all because i think you
have to have a balance between sort of
this repetition hearing the same stuff
over and over again and having something
new because at a certain point the brain
turns off you can't keep on forcing the
brain to repeat the same stuff over and
over again
and it's good to to vary it a bit
i did a video about interleaving or this
idea
again there's a gentleman called robert
bjork who is has done videos on youtube
and explains that
rather than trying to totally learn a
block of of information we are far
better to
spend some time with it put it aside
forget it go back to it again relearn it
forget it go back to it later
that form of interleaved learning
is in fact more effective
than trying to block learn something
so i think you should be guided by your
interest level when you sense that it's
now boring to you uh even if you don't
understand it all it's time to move on
how to learn a rare language like
estonian for which there are not much
current content i want to reach an
academic level studies known in the
future but i find it hard to make any
progress
fine
yeah hard for me to say
i don't know what's available in
estonian estonia
is a very um
with it country when it comes to
the internet and internet access and the
digital society
so i mean it wouldn't surprise me
to find good audio and text content for
estonian in the case of romanian which
is also you know it's not rare but it's
not that popular language i did find
content i found an audio book
for which i was able to find
the digital text online
uh i found resources on for grammar on
romanian i just did a lot of googling
and and i found stuff for romanian so my
only advice is
see what you can find i have not tried
studying estonia so i can't really say
fabio says i like to write a lot do you
think it is useful and help to improve
speaking absolutely
absolutely writing is extremely
extremely important when you're writing
you have more time to think you're
more inclined to
to look up
you know certain
grammar structures and patterns and then
try to use it correctly and all of this
helps to form good habits in the
language
um
it's it's to my mind i mean the written
language
in a sense it's just a recording a
written recording of what someone said
and so
you're in fact recording yourself and it
prepares you for speaking
so uh writing is great and
typically when i for example when i was
studying chinese i wrote a lot
and i i treat writing as a as a part of
speaking so i try not to have
a very casual style when i speak and a
very formal style when i write i prefer
to make my writing equal my speaking so
when i speak i speak a sort of a neutral
uh
you know
variant of the language and when i write
i write as if i were speaking and i find
it very helpful to improve our our
confidence our
you know control of the grammar and so
forth and so on
jonathan says i was wondering how to
keep speaking in a language when you
aren't talking to a native speaker i do
two three meet ups with japanese people
a week in vancouver
um
okay i mean i have to admit that i am
less concerned about
uh speaking with people because i find
that if i maintain my language through
listening and reading i don't lose my
speaking ability i might be a little
rusty but very quickly in fact
uh
i'm continuing to add my vocabulary i'm
continuing to
to uh increase my familiarity with the
language my comprehension so it doesn't
bother me but if you want to speak with
people your meetups that's a good thing
to do you can find people online for
exchange but as i say personally i'm not
worried about it i have 15 languages i
can't possibly be speaking to
speakers of 15 different languages all
the time but it's very easy for me to
throw a cd in my car and listen to
chinese or or ukrainian or korean or
romanian or whatever i want
okay next question from alexander from
ukraine i've learned english for eight
months using ada hoag methods i love my
learning but now i'm in turkey and i
need to know some turkish so my question
is can i learn two languages at the same
time because i find it
too much difficult all right
um i mean if you're in turkey and and i
presume you're living in turkey then
yeah you've got tremendous motivation to
learn turkish and you're surrounded
by this turkish language environment so
i would definitely go at
turkish and your english is not going to
suffer your english will only improve
while you go at turkey so then i would
focus on turkish forget about english
in fact you could probably use english
english language resources to learn
turkish so that you to that extent
you're maintaining your english but you
will find that if you now go and learn
turkish
forget english
you won't forget it but if you don't put
any effort sort of effort into english
when you go back to english you'll be
better
it's happened to me several times i
don't know why that happens but it
happens all right
merit here do you think it is hard to
learn languages whose alphabet is not
latin
absolutely absolutely it is um we are so
familiar i have that experience myself
having learned chinese japanese korean
and russian ukrainian
it's always easier to read in our own
language
but that's part of the sense of
achievement that you're able to read
this other writing system so i mean if
you decide to learn a language you have
to accept
all of the conditions of that language
and that may include learning a
different uh writing system but it is
certainly harder raphael says i am at
beginner level of swedish and such i
find it hard to find audios that i can
understand so do you read more than
listen at the beginner level and switch
to listening more as you progress
um
what i find and i i hope you've used all
the resources we have in our swedish
library
i tend at the beginning to want to
listen and read to the same material
listen to and read the same material
because it reinforces it
but
for example in ukrainian i couldn't find
a lot of material that had audio so i
end up reading more
and it's easier to read you can pick
your way through it you can save words
and phrases
uh at link for example
uh so it's easier to find material and
it's easier to work you know it's easier
to read
reading improves your ability your
comprehension ability so if you have
uh i'll add to that in term in
portuguese it was the same way i i
discovered these wonderful portuguese
podcasts from portugal
they didn't have any transcripts but i
had done enough reading in portuguese
plus portuguese is very similar to
spanish that i was able then to just
listen
so
the activities we engage in will depend
on on the resources that we're able to
find
but as a general rule yes it's easier to
read than to listen
if i have a lot of audio content
available i will listen a lot in fact at
the beginning even if i don't understand
it as long as i can go back and access
the text
read it again
go back and listen still don't
understand go back and read it again so
i go through that sort of process until
my brain gets
used to the language
and i guess
as i progress i would say that
more and more i tend to read and listen
independently so if there's a good
podcast i listen to the podcast if
there's something interesting that i
want to read
i'll simply read it and i won't be quite
as concerned about matching audio to
text as i am at the beginning all right
terry says you also say to read and
listen to the topic that you're
interested in by doing this you also
meet the same words doesn't help a lot
in everyday conversation i'm fond of
mechanics i only know boats and nuts
yeah
obviously if you stay in a very narrow
area then that will limit your
um
vocabulary so if if you're interested in
mechanics and you're only reading about
bolts and nuts that's going to limit
your
um
you know your vocabulary so you've got
to try to find something else whether it
be history or or uh you know
drama or whatever the other thing is yes
in terms of conversations you have to
expose yourself to content that's more
typical of everyday conversation so that
could be maybe watching television shows
or movies or uh some of the content in
terms of english that we have you know
discussions interviews uh that kind of
thing
you have to try to vary it i think the
simple answer is even though your
interest is mechanics you do have to try
to
vary
uh the kind of things you're listening
to conversational stuff is really good i
i think very good to learn from
a dialogue two people like a genuine
conversation people talking
and which was then subsequently
transcribed rather than a dialogue that
was artificially uh written
all right uh
ken asked who is she so special who
created it how much of the basics is
covered uh i created it i i
i don't believe in this concept of the
basics uh there is a language you can
start at any level some words some
things that seem to be basic you won't
learn until six months later some things
that may not be so basic you catch on to
right away uh the big thing about who is
she is that the vocabulary gets a little
more difficult and the lang the
sentences get a little longer as the
thing progresses
okay vladimir says hello see first of
all i want to support all your efforts
for improving the site and make
something new like this one language
said oh yeah language test a few weeks
ago
uh i have one question uh and one advice
i'm interested uh that you learned
which means i'm interested about most
interesting thing that you learned about
portuguese would make special advice
make little games and quiz on link
connected with language learning all
we're playing all right
so
uh
what was the most interesting thing
about portuguese and and also suggesting
that we should have more games um
portuguese
i would say that um i've spent been the
portuguese three or four times haven't
been to brazil and so therefore i was
more interested in
the portuguese from portugal
um
even though the portuguese from brazil
in a way is easier to understand they
pronounce their vowels somewhat more
clearly
what was interesting to me is that i
discovered
a very interesting series of podcasts
put out by portuguese radio and i spent
a lot of time listening to that podcast
and that then made it possible for me
when i visited portugal to speak with
people so the interest really was a in
the podcast and b in the ability to
communicate because the first time i
went to portugal even though i had spent
a few months with this was before we had
it at link uh living language whatever
tried to and i figured it would be easy
and i went to portugal and of course
they all spoke to me in english because
they immediately identified the fact
that i wasn't very strong in portuguese
after lots of listening to these
podcasts the next time i went to
portugal i was able to carry on in
portuguese so that was very satisfying
games yeah i know this is one of the
many many things that they're looking at
to try and make the site better
um
but uh you know
slowly slowly
uh okay ben here i've been studying
japanese i think for about five months
when listening to podcasts i can
understand quite a bit but i find myself
constantly translating in my head
uh but uh okay
yeah translating in your head it slowly
goes away part of it is
don't worry about trying to nail down
the meaning a hundred percent
uh
if you're translating partly it's
because you're trying to like really
nail down the meaning just
the language is fuzzy to you it's it's
not your native language you don't fully
understand it you have a 60 70 percent
at times a clear 100 percent at times a
20
understanding of what's going on
learn to accept that
but stay in that fuzzy unclear
uh sort of mode and gradually as your
brain gets more and more used to the the
structures of the new language it's
going to become clearer that's better
than trying to go to the translation to
find out exactly what was said at least
that's how i approach it
okay
uh
tell us here why watch movie scenes more
difficult
okay yeah movies are difficult don't
assume otherwise i lived in japan for
nine years
and i was conducting business in
japanese and i could have conversations
with people in japanese on
very important business matters but when
i watched the japanese movie on tv
i had lots of trouble to understand it
it's it's quick
it's you're not in the context you're
not part of it
uh often the context
whether it's social or historical or
whatever is not familiar to you
very often dialogues in movies are not
natural
all of these things make it difficult so
movies are difficult i don't treat
movies as a learning opportunity but
rather as a reward for having studied
the language and so i enjoy i enjoy them
but i don't i think it's not as good a
learning uh situation
as listening and reading for example but
that's it's all a matter of what we like
to do so if you like watching movies by
all means do so but don't assume that
it's easy it's difficult
song only steve you say one of the most
important things about language learning
is to notice what happens in the
language you'll be more specific on this
learn mandarin chinese and i would like
to know how to use this for my language
learning is this something i can train
yeah i mean this is a very important
point noticing
um some people don't notice things i've
given the example if i have when i was
in japan and i'd have visitors from
canada in the lumber business and i'd
introduce them to mr kato
and he would say my name is kato
and i say hello mr cato
because k-a-t-o in their minds is cato
and they didn't pay attention
i said his name is kato he said his name
is kato and still they said kato and
there's all kinds of examples so you
have to
in terms of noticing you have to want to
notice number one you have to want to
notice
number two for example in link if you
save words and save phrases or when
reading if you underline structures you
know you're learning mandarin chinese
okay obviously
you have to begin by by noticing that
they say
are you going they need shibuchu okay so
then you go not go so there's a new
structure you start to notice you start
to notice the different patterns you
know josue
like even though something rather you
have to start to notice these structures
you have to notice certain things in the
pronunciation you have to pay attention
the kinds of things that i do are
underline saving links lots of exposure
per se
naturally you will start to notice more
and more and just as with a crossword
puzzle the more things you have already
noticed
that will enable you to notice other
things but you have to have this
conscious desire to notice you have to
notice the pronunciation i mentioned the
example before that
sometimes people who are not
native speakers of english they'll
say they're spanish speakers
they'll see words like word bird heard
w-o-r-d
d h e a r d and they'll think that
they're pronounced differently
word bird heard are pronounced the same
even though they're written differently
so you have to notice that you have to
notice uh you know the emphasis in in in
words so all of these things take a
deliberate effort to sort of notice and
that in turn will create habits so i
hope that helps to
uh explain uh the whole issue of
noticing which is absolutely key the
biggest thing i think
is um you know lots of exposure
christian
steve is it advisable to learn two
languages at the same time if not how
many months should i study
okay i am not
i personally i'm not a fan
of um
studying more than one language
at the same time let's see i lost this
now let's see
okay okay mark here so on the i'm not a
fan of studying more than one language
at the same time
mark do you think about it i'm in my 50s
and i'm just starting i have latin and
did well blah blah blah and i want to
read my favorite authors in the original
i'm planning on starting with spanish
i'm in california any other advice from
a mature learner
that's just starting on a living
non-computer language
okay i mean
50s that's young you're 20 years younger
than i am not 20 but 15.
if you are motivated to read authors
in the original that is a tremendous
asset that's a tremendous asset
so you should pick one language say
spanish because that's going to be the
easiest
and i would go i mean go straight to
link do all of the beginner content and
link we have some excellent content not
only who is she we have some content
there that will help you with tenses a
variety of sort of things that will get
you launched and then very soon
very soon after starting into the that
kind of content
uh you should move on to your novels and
we have novels in our library here at
link and all of those have audio and
text the advantage of audio and text is
you take a lesson you listen to the
audio you don't understand it but it
gets gives you some momentum
to go then and read it and save words
and phrases and then you listen again
and and it's just there's a lot of more
resonance you're interacting with the
text that way and i would say that for
at least a year
you should do most of your uh reading
and listening
at link
because there you have all these tools
that will help you acquire vocabulary
and get used to the language listen to
it but thereafter you should be able to
buy spanish books on kindle and you can
use kindle dictionary and just stay in
kindle and keep reading
so uh yeah i think the biggest thing is
that
you are motivated to read
um in the language that's excellent
victor what do you think about genki i
don't know what genki is
so i i unless you mean anki
and i'm not a big anki fan simply
because
i learned so many words that i would be
spending all my time on anki so i prefer
to focus an hour or so a day that i have
on listening and reading a little bit of
review of words but fundamentally i'm
spending my time doing things that i
find enjoyable but people who find it
enjoyable to review their flashcards at
anki would find anki enjoyable so it
entirely depends on what you like to do
eunes thank you mr steve i'd like to say
that i read a novel that has translated
my original language oops it keeps
popping on me here
in a second
uh that is translating my reason i read
its translation
from my target language okay very good i
mean i uh it is sometimes easier to read
a book
that was translated from your language
because translations tend to be easier
to read but anything you read is good as
long as you're interested in it tiago
how many words approximately for romance
language are enough to reduce the rhythm
and start learning
another language
you know what i don't have a number for
that it's more a matter of
uh motivation when you're tired of one
language move to another when you're
tired of one piece of content move to
another
any tips on making pronunciation perfect
or something perfect i don't believe in
perfect i think perfect
is a bad
goal in language learning at any stage
communication
the ability to understand the ability to
express yourself that's what matters now
in terms of improving your pronunciation
i i think a lot of listening is
important
you can't pronounce what you can't hear
and when you start with the language you
don't hear
some of the sounds that are different
that you haven't heard before
but beyond that i would put a major
emphasis on intonation
one of the things you can do at link is
to pick a paragraph
listen to it and then
maybe do it
phrase or sentence at a time and
eventually paragraph at a time and try
to repeat that yourself focusing on
intonation if you get the music the
rhythm the intonation right
then
you'll have a better chance with the
rest of of you know getting all of the
other
you know pronunciation of individual
words right
alex please tell me which is the best
way to learn english idioms just
memorizing them or is it better
i don't memorize
definitely just listen to content of
interest listen to content that has a
lot of idioms save the idioms as phrases
review them
notice them underline them when you see
them make a point of noticing them when
you hear them and slowly because there
is an
almost unlimited number of idioms you're
not going to learn them all you
shouldn't have that as a goal
i think idioms are okay but there's lots
of other things that you need to learn
in the language and i don't see the
idioms as an exception you just need to
do a lot of listening and reading and
try to pay attention
okay
mel do you have
did you have the expression that
changing your diet while living in other
countries affected positively or
negatively your learning experience
no effect whatsoever
uh but
uh
one of the advantages of traveling and
experiencing different cultures
uh
and speaking different languages is that
you experience other aspects of their
culture such as the diet but it has had
no effect that i'm aware of on my
ability to learn
vladimir says tell me do you have a
situation where you mess up with words
from different languages if you say one
funny personal anecdote
thanks they okay
yeah i can't really think of uh i'm sure
i do that but i can't think now of a
specific example of that
uh particularly with the slavic
languages at times i don't know if this
particular word is ukrainian russian or
czech so occasionally but
once you get
into it more you tend to
do it less so when transitioning from
one language to another this tends to
happen but once you're in a
in the language it doesn't happen so
often alexander asked do i have a
favorite language the one i'm learning
thiago says i'd like to learn spanish
once i speak portuguese should i look
for advanced content
i
i if i understand correctly you are you
speak portuguese uh therefore yes you
can start in at a very high level in in
spanish absolutely joaquin says what do
you think about trying to learn the
words of songs songs are great if you're
interested in songs absolutely the key
is to uh
to study from things that interest you
so songs will have a lot of colloquial
language the vocabulary is a bit limited
but obviously if that's what you want
they're interested it's great content to
learn from
how is it possible to study
chinese because the letters are very
different yes you have to learn the
characters that's a lot of work major
obstacle in learning chinese is the
characters so you have to be prepared to
invest a lot of time in learning
characters
pedro says steve my native language is
portuguese and i want to learn french
and english in the same time do you have
any tips
i would recommend that you focus on
whichever language you are strongest in
i would do that for the first six months
and then i would focus on the other
language
in the next six months but i i have
found personally that it's difficult
to uh to do two at the same time but
other people have different experiences
nissarin says i find it difficult in the
u.s pronunciation what can i do to
improve pronunciation do a lot of
listening do a lot of listening and as i
said earlier
practice say it link grab a paragraph
and listen along and then try to read it
again and try to imitate the intonation
uh steve you always said that it's
important to study using interesting
content i do like to listen to language
learning content would that help me when
discussing other subjects and would that
give me the necessary vocabulary well no
it will make you strong in in that
particular subject so
if you want to if you know you're going
to be discussing
uh other subjects
then
then uh
you're gonna have to read up on those
subjects if you're gonna be discussing
business for example or politics or
literature you're gonna have to find the
content that relates to
uh that subject so i think the important
thing with content is obviously you're
going to read about things that are of
interest to you but if you have a need
professional need to become competent in
discussing other subjects you're going
to have to go and find
that kind of content
okay
all right well i'm going to call it
that's we've just been about an hour
here i've tried to answer everyone's
question i may not have been able to
answer everyone
um we'd be interested in your comments
uh i i maybe should close
by saying that um you know you can
contact me let's see if we can make this
work here
you can follow me
on twitter facebook youtube
um
i strongly believe i mean we created
link for a reason
and i think for those of you who are on
link
i didn't have a chance to go to anyone's
profile today but it's important to
create links if if anyone follows me at
link if you go to my profile you'll see
just how many links i create
it's helping me to notice
it
it's an indication of just the amount of
content that i have consumed i've
listened to and have read
and i think the goal and it's often
useful when we're learning a language to
have a very you know measurable goal and
to me the number of links that i create
is is the best indication of how active
i've been in learning the language and
with language learning if we are active
if we are active we're going to make
progress so i strongly recommend those
of you that are on link
to um
to create a lot of links and and really
force yourself to to cover a lot of
content
okay
that's it
uh
there we are yes this right this webinar
was recorded so um those of you who
missed it will be able to listen to it
all right then thank you very much
bye for now and thank you for joining me